moi je trouve que c'est un exercice
éminemment cruel le casting quand comme
je disais c'est une décision qui peut
changer qui peut changer ta vie et en
même temps demande d'être convaincant en
2 minutes dans un dans un dans des
bureaux souvent cafards on demande
d'imaginer que il y a une fanfare qui
joue devant toi et que il y a un aigle
sur ton bras et que et que je sais pas
quoi et et en fait tu es juste dans des
locaux tout pourri et le mec passe des
coups de fil en même temps qu'il parle
était juste un numéro dans la journée et
parce que c'est cruel et que c'est assez
qui a de l'humain et de l'inhumain bah
ça peut être drôle alors du coup on voit
qu'à ce moment-là vous prenez